llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france24 me acompaña el estudio
àngel hablando con daniela la saludo
bienvenida el gobierno de cuba anunció
medidas económicas para tratar de
apaciguar la crisis o la raúl pues mire
el gobierno anunció que levantará desde
el lunes y hasta el 31 de diciembre
algunas restricciones sobre la cantidad
de alimentos medicamentos y productos de
aseo que pueden llevar los viajeros que
lleguen a la isla esto como una aparente
pequeña concesión hacia los
manifestantes que llevan días
protestando por las condiciones
económicas del país hoy en día existen
ciertos límites en las cantidades de
artículos que se pueden entrar a la
nación a partir de los cuales se cobra
un arancel pero eso va a cambiar
temporalmente desde el próximo lunes
se encuentra exento de pago si no se
paga
los derechos arancelarios y se autoriza
su importación no comercial hasta 10
kilogramos es decir cualquier persona
hoy puede dar 10 kilogramos de
medicamento y no paga nada los alimentos
aseos y medicamentos sin límite de valor
de importación
y libre de pago de arancel daniela
continuamos en el continente americano
la inflación de argentina sigue al alza
raúl o y los precios de la canasta
familiar se dieron levemente en junio
pero siguen siendo altos si se comparan
con mayo se incrementaron en 32 % y si
la comparación se hace frente al mismo
mes de hace un año el alza desde el 50,2
por ciento los precios al consumidor en
argentina también hoy son 25 por ciento
más alto de lo que eran a comienzos del
2021 lo que mantiene a ese país en la
cima del ranking de los más
inflacionarios de suramérica sólo
superado por venezuela los productos que
más subieron en el mes
raúl los relacionados con
telecomunicaciones y adivinen bebidas
alcohólicas y tabaco
danielle la organización mundial del
comercio buscaba un acuerdo para reducir
con los subsidios con los subsidios a la
pesca los miembros de este organismo
multilateral llevan dos décadas tratando
de acercar posturas en torno a un
acuerdo que limite los subsidios que
muchos gobiernos otorgan a la industria
pesquera y que en algunos casos
patrocinan la
pesca ilegal y la sobrepesca este jueves
volvieron a reunirse y aunque no hubo
pacto al menos si hay un texto que va a
servir de base para sellarlo en
diciembre la divergencia está en el
trato que se les daría a los países
desarrollados y en vías de desarrollo
estos últimos piden que la prohibición
de subvenciones se les aplique con
cierta flexibilidad porque sus economías
dependen mucho de esta actividad pero el
temor expresado en el seno de la bbc es
que si esperan más pues ya no van a
quedar peces en el mundo escuchemos and
sustainable face las prácticas pesqueras
insostenibles continúan afectando a
nuestros océanos alentados por el apoyo
financiero de los gobiernos que estamos
tratando de poner en regla el momento de
actuar se acabó hace mucho tiempo es
long of you y facer acordó un pago
millonario para resolver demandas por
violar normas de competencia bueno
primero aclaremos que no tienen que ver
con vacunas pero la multinacional
estadounidense y dos de sus subsidiarias
acordaron pagar 345 millones de dólares
para resolver demandas por aumentos
injustificados en el precio
del epp y pena este es un dispositivo
auto inyectable para el tratamiento de
una reacción alérgica potencialmente
mortal conocida como anafilaxia el
litigio antimonopolio data de 2016
cuando se presentaron numerosas demandas
colectivas en eeuu alegando que en 2007
un paquete de este dispositivo costaba
100 dólares y hoy en día cuesta 650 con
este acuerdo la empresa evita extender
ese lío jurídico para que no llegue a un
juicio que podría representarle
millonarios recursos
varela indicadores la bolsa de nueva
york cerró mixta en una sesión marcada
por muy buenos resultados empresariales
sobre todo los del sector financiero las
bolsas de américa latina también
tuvieron cierres dispares con un
importante ascenso en la plaza bursátil
mexicana
para finalizar nos trae como cifra el
dia 360.000 estas fueron las peticiones
de subsidio por desempleo en eeuu en la
semana que terminó el pasado sábado esta
es la cifra más baja desde el inicio de
la pandemia lejos del pico de 6,8
millones y acercándose a las 200.000
semanales que se registraban en promedio
antes de la crisis así de genera como
siempre gracias por toda la información
económica a ustedes también gracias
continúen con nosotros